Now at certain points in the course you may need to enter coordinate pairs using
of course typical coordinate notation with parenthesis around the outside of
them that contain fractions for the coordinate values. This is actually a little
bit tricky to do in mathquill so we are going to talk about who you do this. I'm
going to tell you exactly how to type this out. So let's say that we wanted to
type. So, let's say that this is the order pair that we want to type. 3 over 4,
negative 1 and a half. I'm going to tell you exactly what keys to press. And
then what will appear as you type each one of them. So, the first thing we have
is this open parentheses. But when you type that, both parentheses appear. The
next step is to type a forward slash. At which point, the space inside the two
parentheses, will turn into the input for a fraction. So there will be a line,
and a space for you to enter the numerator and the denominator. Your cursor at
this point will be in the numerator. And as unintuitive as it might seem, what
we want to do, is to get the cursor to be right here, inside the first
parentheses. But before we have the option to type inside the fraction. So you
just need to type a left arrow key to move the cursor over here. Then you can
type a comma, which will be the comma between our two coordinates. At this point
your cursor will be right here, between the comma and the fraction spot. So you
need to type the left arrow key to move it back here. Now we just need to create
the first coordinate. Then you need to type a forward slash again. Which will
create another spot for a fraction to be input. And then you can use the arrow
keys as you normally would between fractions to go to each numerator and
denominator and enter the values that you want to. So you can see that whats
happening here, in terms of the order that things appeared in over here
depending on what I told you to type, that you have to actually create the spot
for the Second coordinate as a fraction before you create the first one. If you
try to create one fraction and then put a comma, it's not going to work. Another
option would be for you to create two separate fraction spots and then move to
the spot between the two of them and then put a comma. This is just a way that
works really easily for me. But of course, as always, you can experiment and
figure out what works best for you. So, thinking about how you create 2
coordinates that are each fractions. I'd like you to try out typing each of
these coordinate pairs. First one we have is 3 4ths, negative 1 half. Then we
have 1, 2 over 7. And then we have negative 1 8th, 3. So just play around with
these, and see if you can get comfortable with this format.